Đấy đón chính thức tổ vi thư tô lâm và phù nhân ngô phương lih,
công đoán đại biểu cấp cao Việt Nam thăm cấp nhắn nước cận hà dân chủ nhân dân lào.
Dự lấy khi điểm năm nay làm cuộc kháng nước cận hà dân chủ nhân dân lào,
và đông chủ chỉ cuộc gặp các cào giữa đảng cộng sản Việt Nam,
và đảng nhân dân cách nặng lào, đã diễn ra trong thế tại phù chủ tịch.
Theo nghĩ thức cao nhất, sánh trong quyền thuốc cu ra,
tổ viết thư chủ tích nước lào thông luôn xí xuất liết và phù nhân chủ chỉ lấy đón.
Bằng xe trở tổ vi thư tô lâm và phù nhân,
công đoán này biểu cấp cao Việt Nam thiam và phù chủ tích trong sự trào mừng nông dệt của đông đào các học sinh,
và người dân thủ đô viên chân với những bộ tràng phục chuyển thống của nhân dân các dân thuốc lào,
và là cơ hành nước trên tay,
tổ vi thư chủ tích nước lào thông luôn xí xuất liết,
ra tận cửa xe trào đón tổ vi thư tô lâm và phù nhân,
công đoán này biểu cấp cao Việt Nam.
Chào chuyển thăm,
dự kiến tổ vi thư tô lâm sẽ có khu hội đam với tổ vi thư chủ tích nước lào thông luôn xí xuất liết,
hội kiến thủ tưởng sọn xây xí văn đòn,
chủ tích khu hội xây sọn phôn phôn phôn vi hành,
tham các đồng chiên quyền lãnh đảo các cao của lào,
dự lẽ kiến đệm nămu năm của khánh,
đặt vào qua tại đại thử nghiệm các chiến xí vô dành,
pháp biểu chính xách tại học viện chính chi hành chính cúc ra lào,
và một số hoạt động khác,
đồng chủ chỉ của các cao giữa đảng cộng sân Việt Nam và đảng nhân dân khách nặng lào.
Nhân chuyển thăm,
hành bên dự kiến sẽ kiết một số văn kiện hấp các quan trọng,
tạo hành lăng pháp liếm,
mở ra những định hướng ở tác mới,
phù hợp với yêu cầu phát triển của mũ nước,
và lửa trung của hai dân tộc.
Tết tục làm sâu sắc hơn mới quan hệ đặc biệt Việt Nam lào trong tiền hi mới,
chuyển thăm tiếp tục khẩn định sự quyết tâm của lãnh đảo hai đảng,
hành nước,
luôn dành sự quan tâm đặc biệt trong việc kế thừa,
và phát liếm mối quan hệ hiểu nghĩ vì đại,
đoàn kết đặc biệt,
hôm tác tận diễn Việt Nam lào,
lào Việt Nam,
phát triển của hợp với yêu cầu,
tâm diền,
và lửa ý chính lợp của hai nước trong gia đình mới.